aujourd'hui 10 mars est une journée très
importante pour moi car c'est
l'anniversaire de quelqu'un que je
chéris michel onfray et on s'en sort on
s'entend mieux bah il c'est calme un peu
sur l'islam maintenant c'est mon ami
kaka que je chéris quelqu'un que j'aime
c'est quelqu'un qui est mon idole
je sais qui c'était quelqu'un dont je
suis fou nadal à nice et qui sait de
chèques norris n'a pas vous auriez vous
j'aurais bien autres animateurs voilà un
peu moins bon goût douteux
arthur fallait dire beaucoup moins trois
de ses coûts mais comme c'est un ami
j'ai essayé de ménager
c'est votre ami non observez vous aurez
un contrôle c'était un peu différent
[Rires]
c'est quand même se réjouir
la bonne réponse elle est là bravo est
le dilemme une passion non ein le
bâillon voilà à canon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
gc j'aurais fait
[Applaudissements]
ouais
mais rien pour lui trolard les mois et
en attendant c'est avec vous à le faire
[Applaudissements]
c'est m vous avez n'a reculé m je ne
fais pas monsieur péter loi je pense
vraiment que je souhaitais voir ces
paraphes c'est une dar k le show mode
[Applaudissements]